[Applause]
Alex when your shift starts you could
just come in through the front door
my name is not Alex it's Alexander Wang
fashion designer keeper of shadows and
master of the realm of fabrics okay but
you're also twenty five minutes late I
know I'm so sorry there was a bunch of
traffic in the nethersphere also I'm
still getting used to the schedule of
being ybarra back plus I seem to have
misplaced my uniform and buy a misplaced
I mean deliberately tossed into the
furnace of Hades so that the polyester
nylon blend would melt into the Earth's
core never to be seen by a corporeal
soul for the rest of time I am fashion
incarnate after all however since I do
need to keep this job for three more
weeks in order to settle a bet with
Diane von Furstenberg
I have prepared suggestions for new
uniforms option 1 this length of cement
gray Tunisian linen super heavy horrible
to the touch does not have arm head or
body holes and costs a cool $900 option
2 this handful of cement gray yarn super
heavy as well somehow flowy fits with
every size and every outfit and it's
still at $3,000 ready to wear and
finally my pesto has East all this
cement gray cinder block from the bottom
of the Aegean Sea
not at all heavy goes with any house
and somehow maintains the classic but
ultra modern look and only costs $30,000
I'll go past those tables Thanks
actually this is nice Alex